[Musique]
bien le bonsoir chers auditoire me v'là
seul sans accessoire bien sobre et
minimale car ce soir je vous narre
l'histoire d'une espèce animale doté du
pouvoir de savoir mais qui le manie mal
une espèce de primate doux et le mets ta
conscience qui a formalisé les maths
puis en extirpe à les sciences pour
mieux dépendre d'automates carburant à
l'essence un mammifère à deux pattes à
peine dans l'adolescence une petite
crotte de blattes dans la grande arbres
essence qui arbore déjà les stigmates de
son culte de la croissance
pourtant dans son enfance l'espèce
prenez pas tout l'espace faut dire pour
sa défense sapiens se reconnaissait sa
place ti prédateur mais armature de
l'equilibre de mère nature chasseurs
cueilleurs un peu de culture et ouais ça
tient un salaire matures sauf que très
vite tout cela s'effrite l'âge en
espèces comprend ensuite que la nature
lui est gratuite et homo sapiens en
profite délaissant sa vie d'ermite
abandonnant la terre cuite c'est
maintenant la ville qu'ils habitent avec
l'argent c'est implicite survient
l'avènement d'une élite et c'est là que
tout se précipite puisque une élite on
limite on en adopter la conduite malgré
sa fonction parasites et plus la vie se
délite plus on part à la poursuite d'une
soi-disant réussite telle que décrite
par leurs mythes que l'on peut croître
sans limites qu'on peut pomper dans la
terre la truffe et le dynamite pour
s'abreuver des cratères sans penser au
lendemain de cuite
l'espèce en a creusé les entrailles elle
a découvert le pétrole puis s'est vautré
dans la faille jusqu'à en devenir folle
elle a scarifié d'une entaille jusqu'au
plus petit des atolls s'est mise à viser
les étoiles sauf que depuis tout
s'étiole comme empêtré dans la toile
tissée par l'appât du pactole prise dans
une espèce de léthargie dans sept ans
rui de l'énergie c'est ainsi que
l'espèce s'est assagi la propagande a
ressurgi sans plus personne pour
s'insurger et fait advenir une gabegie
dont les plus riches ont fait leur jeu
dans l'hyper flux de la croissance le
superflu de l'apparence la plus value de
l'abondance et l'errance on se complaît
plus la transe est intense plus on danse
en cadence on s'élance à chaque couplet
ça produit sa dépense se rempli la panse
et sa panse panser ses plaies ah ça on
adore le plastique dont il confère un
doux confort cette boîte de pandore on
lastic may à l'enfer dans ses temps
forts ça fait de l'or c'est fantastique
mais c'est le cancer souvent quand sort
c'est dur c'est fort même élastique mais
dans la mer ça sème la mort
nous y voilà chers auditoire je ne
termine pas mon histoire car pour le
reste c'est à vous de voir ce qu'on va
tous devoir en faire je pourrais passer
pour une bonne poire mais pour nous
autres j'ai bon espoir de s'arrêter au
purgatoire avant d'échoir dans un enfer
arrêtez de vouloir du pouvoir et le
promouvoir l'accessoire tous et avoir
qui nous rend fiers
enfin respecter le territoire voir que
la gloire est illusoire qu'elle fout la
fois dans l'atmosphère il n'y a pas de
moyen de les savoir pas de preuves
notoire vers une victoire
mais je fais le choix d'y croire dur
comme fer
alors vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué
je suis un adorateur des mots un slameur
amateurs et j'ai mis cette passion au
service de mon activisme alors forcément
quand j'écris sur l'état de notre
écosystème c'est pas toujours très
joyeux ce que j'ai à partager on fait
avec le matériel pour nous donne et ce
texte homo sapiens je l'écris ya trois
ans à l'occasion d'une émission sur
youtube en direct devant des milliers
d'internautes et si vous avez tenu
jusqu'à la fin vous aurez peut-être
n'opter qu'il se termine sur un ton
plutôt optimiste je pourrais passer pour
une bonne poire mais pour nous autres
j'ai bon espoir de s'arrêter au
purgatoire avant des fois avant d'en
faire
un optimisme modéré on est d'accord que
le purgatoire c'est pas cocktails à
volonté et lambada tous les soirs mais
franchement à l'époque pour qui connaît
mon histoire la moindre note d'espoir
était déjà un petit miracle
2010 neuf femmes et 26 ans environ
j'étais en complète des pressions
dont coquille vide démotivé
désemparé un procrastinateurs
pathologique
en fait j'attends des fatalistes re que
la marée monte une marée noire et
considère génocidaire où se noyait mes
angoisses
dans le fond j'attendais d'avoir le
courage d'en finir par moi même et pour
faire tout ça benj abusé de youtube des
séries et du cannabis je m'auto
détruisez à petit feu et m'interdisais
quoi que ce soit productif
c'est donc dans les tréfonds de cette
spirale infernale
qu'un jour j'ai fait une rencontre qui a
changé ma vie au bout du bout de
l'apathie je suis tombé sur la poésie il
y avait une panne d'internet et il
fallait quelque chose pour continuer de
fuir la réalité un truc bien inutile et
sans le savoir d'un j'ai fait le truc le
plus utile de ma vie écrire mon premier
slam
je me suis rapidement rendu compte que
j'appelle mes mots quand je pèse mes
mots et me pense l'âme quand je pense
slam
avec le slam j'ai petit à petit remonté
la pente j'ai extérioriser mon mal être
j'ai cassé mon isolement en fréquentant
des scènes ouvertes où j'ai trouvé une
conscience en moi que je croyais avoir
perdu pour toujours
et même au bout d'un moment j'ai trouvé
de l'espoir
sauf qu'à part dans ma tête rien n'avait
vraiment changé
on est d'accord que la marée noire
continue de menacer toujours plus et
avec elle ce besoin pressant d'agir oui
mais maintenant
j'avais un outil pour toucher les foules
j'avais une place à prendre dans la
lutte et surtout j'avais de plus en plus
d'amis activistes surmotivés au contact
de tous ceux que la poésie a mis sur mon
chemin je suis passé en quelques années
de
désemparé dépressif à slamer
convalescent puis artiste engagé pour
terminer
artiviste radical un mec qui emploie
autant les mots que la désobéissance
civile pour endiguer la marée noire
espère et provoqué la marée verte
journalisme environnemental avec le
collectif du gie terre camp climat
blocage de la société générale du siège
de total et du ministère on peut dire
que la poésie mami a regonflé à bloc
sauf que plus que jamais on a besoin
d'une révolution culturelle imminente
et pour ça moi je rêve d'un monde où les
générations futures grandissent bercé
dans le respect de la nature un respect
insufflé par leurs films ou leur chanson
préférée
par du street art à chaque coin de rue
et pourquoi pas par des slams vues sur
youtube
je le regrette très souvent mais homo
sapiens est ainsi fait que pour
provoquer le changement
quelques mots susurrés droite au coeur
valmy le rapport du giec expliqué au
cerveau
et je croyais être tombé sur le hobby le
plus inutile qu'ils soient et trouver un
art qui me permet de toucher des
centaines de milliers de coeurs sur
internet sur scène et je l'espère ici ce
soir
et depuis 2010 9 la poésie a guidé mes
pas jusqu'à ce d'erbine un écovillage en
suède où je vis aligné avec mes valeurs
et où je participe avec la communauté à
promouvoir partout en europe un mode de
vie éco responsable
et donc si vous raconte cette histoire
aujourd'hui c'est parce que je crois que
beaucoup en partage les prémices
des gens conscients potentiel moteur de
la révolution écologique
mais
désemparé
isolé qui attendent dans l'angoissé la
solitude la marée montante
alors si c'est ton cas géré un seul
conseil à donner
chercher dans les recoins même les plus
improbables
la passion qui te fera vibrer est
vraiment te plonger dans à 100% et
peut-être que très vite tu ne tendra
plus la marée noire mais participera
provoqué la marée verte si toi tu en as
ta claque
tout attend un déclic si tu veux prendre
des claques mais tu trouves pas
technique tu sens que l'humain craque
comme piégé dans une crique cherche en
vain son ithaque cette fille en tilt
meetic mais les 40 du cac accumule les
low kicks comme le sang dans les flaques
provoquées par des flics étaient là tu
te brac au pied d'un mur en briques
conscient que l'afrique rac comme l'irak
pour le fric mais ne prend pas de prozac
devient plutôt pro zik où est le climat
se détraque du coup nos vies c'est rick
le présent c'est le tarmac l'avenir un
choc thermique il reste pas patrac et
passe à la pratique faut passer à
l'attaqué armée de notre éthique et
casser la baraque tourner ce monde en
bourrique assez leur conte ou plaques
faut donner la réplique mettre en
lumière nos pattes au prix d'une lutte
épique
quasi tout mettre à sac pour revoir les
classiques il faut des gens qui ont
conscience bien plus érudits qualités
qui en sachant ce que dit la science
choisissent la radicalité on a bousillé
nos semences il ya plus un radis de
qualité et on entretient la démence au
vent du beurre de karité et on nous vend
une verte croissance une veine parodie
d'équité du nucléaire à peine puissance
qui nous irradie de chaque côté on fait
la guerre pour de l'essence c'est ce que
ce paradigme a coûté de cette croissance
n'a aucun sens ce faux paradis m'a
quitté c'est l'heure du branle-bas de
combat contre une politique en carton
parce qu'il est trop moche le constat
qu'on va adresser à nos fils ton celui
d'une terre en sale état et recouverte
de béton on a fait péter le thermostat
pour être en tête de peloton on va se
faire battre par le climat est pourtant
lui tend le bâton
on a détruit les habitats des éléphants
jusqu au plancton on est à deux doigts
du trépas à cause d'un système troubles
ton et l'état comme et l'attend un de
prendre le pas tel un mouton jamais repu
face aux repas ça veut pas mettre fin
aux gueules tous font du profit du
résultat cet appétit ça fout les jetons
de l'énergie pour la fiesta et puis tant
pis pour les rejetons
n'attend pas qu'on la fasse pour toi
cette nécessaire évolution
on a besoin de toi pour faire ta dans
notre quête d'absolution il faut faire
tomber l'omerta il n'y a pas d'autre
solution pour endiguer la vendetta
provoqué par nos pollutions des miracles
on en vendait 1 pour entretenir la
diction la vérité c'est qu'en l'état on
sait pas stopper l'extension
faut prendre un autre chemin tant qu'il
est encore temps
repenser le bien commun a retrouvé la
clé des champs mais c'est pas pour
demain faut changer sur le champ quand
l'enjeu c'est l'humain c'est un poil
important faut pas être abattu mais
devenir un battant car tout n'est pas
foutu quand bien même tout fout l'camp
mais faut qu'on s'évertue à lutter
chaque instant pour un élan de vertus
acquis en résistant car tant qu'on ne
fait rien quand ce profit qui prime de
service citoyen face aux acteurs du
crime c'est alors qu'on devient dans
complices que victimes mais nous on se
soutient on refuse la déprime car en
regret du lien temps ensemble en
s'expriment tous ensemble on les tient
ses convictions intimes que la terre va
pas bien que le système se périment puis
le devoir des terriens c'est de se
mettre au régime on n'a pas leurs moyens
la violence légitime pas les grands
quotidiens et lobbys richissime
mais cette rage d'en haut rhin
c'est le pouvoir ultime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]